yeah he's also streaming oh rebecca
harris okay
so how am i gonna play against this guy
you are in his stream lately weren't you
no maybe somebody else yeah
okay let's see if he knows this line
i've played it against him a bunch of
times he always struggles here
i don't think he's figured it out yet no
you don't want to take it
no no
i think lucky river would have taken it
yeah i love
my love pieces yeah that's my material
advantage yeah
i also like pushing my pawns like magnus
oh i thought i had a trap but maybe
maybe it didn't actually work
uh
but now six square is kind of weak
i just uh i'm winning positionally
speaking so i don't wanna
don't wanna take any chance or i could
have taken d6 as well
that's fine
i'm winning positionally so i don't
wanna
take unnecessary chances
we'll take this one
take on d6 and now
it should be over
just take
e5
keeps it keep the extra piece
don't know why he's fighting
seems like there are more
uh useful ways to spend his time in this
tournament
v6 oh i don't think i just take the
queen
okay now resigned